Emme peas discussed their priorities for
the --use next a long-term budget
including fighting climate change
boosting research and innovation and
managing migration 93% of the budget
goes straight back to citizens regions
cities farmers universities and
businesses Parliament gave the green
light to the free trade deal between the
EU and Vietnam it aims to eliminate 99%
of tariffs over the next 10 years and
includes binding rules on climate labor
and human rights about 600,000 women and
girls living in Europe have been
subjected to female genital mutilation
parliament urged the EU to define a
strategy to end FGM around the world and
provide care for survivors Christine
Lagarde addressed the plenary for the
first time as European Central Bank
president and spoke about future
economic policies in the eurozone an
estimated 46,000 dogs are traded every
month between EU countries MEP s called
for an EU action plan to safeguard
animal welfare and illegal trade and
enforce pet registration
you
[Music]